do you have like a really good example
that people could wrap their heads
around in terms of a place where humans
uh have actually made it drastically
better
from a climate perspective uh compared
to maybe the the overarching
thought process around it making it
worse
i mean i i can't think of any place
where we haven't made it much better
because we've made it much better in
what i call the empowered world the
places with low cost reliable energy
that you can that you can use to develop
but also the unempowered world and so i
mean you could take either one but just
just consider the united states i mean
we have every form of climate imaginable
here which is part of why i don't worry
about the the kinds of changes people
are even speculating let alone what i
think is realistic in the global climate
system so you have something like polar
alaska and then you have swampy florida
and where i live in california is not
perfect climate politically but i think
it's a perfect climate
in terms of just you know that that
really nice kind of dry climate near the
ocean
uh so we have every climate imaginable
and we all live really long lives and we
don't have that much trouble with
climate climate is a rhetorical thing in
our lives like it's a rhetorical
negative but life used to be an
emergency in general because people were
poor and in particular it was a climate
emergency uh because of you know even
something like a harvest so maybe a
harvest is a great example just we don't
think now of something like the dust
bowl being possible and it really isn't
possible to us now because of modern
irrigation and other modern technology
but all of this depends on machines
and the ability to use machines at a
very large scale depends on low cost
reliable energy and that's part of why i
think fossil fuels are so crucial
because i'm going to argue this goes to
the second point but they're a uniquely
cost-effective form of energy they're
not at all rapidly replaceable by solar
and wind